[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys uh we we back
out here man we we doing another attic
show another week we've been doing this
for a minute man uh this is like uh you
know we're trying to be consistent man
trying to be consistent and what's funny
hustle is this week i was looking at the
topics man and i'm not saying there
wasn't like a whole lot to talk about
but uh you know because the biggest
thing that i wanted to talk about was
this uh this forza horizon 5 thing so i
was like man we could talk about that
probably half the show just by that
and um i wanted to make this episode
more of a
what the community's talking about you
know what i'm saying not necessarily
what's going on
uh so you know that's what i wanted to
like really direct this episode for
but
i know
i should start putting the number of
these attic shows but i don't i don't
really count them like that so we're
going to say
welcome guys to the attic show episode
today that's what episode it is today uh
where we talk about the past present and
future in gaming i got my co-host with
me hustle motivate what's going on
hustle
everything is going well everything is
going well at it uh as you were in the
middle of your speech i was gonna ask
you did you know what number this was so
we could actually start numbering them i
was i was just i'm so i'm curious to
know anyway i'm just curious to know to
see what number we want
let me look
we can always we can always figure that
out in due time it looks like episode 20
20ish like 23 24. so i think technically
we're on 23.
is the attic show
all right yeah two of my favorite
numbers got me feeling like michael
jordan out here ladies and gentlemen i
hope all is well um i see the topics for
today
well we'll make it through i promise we
will i promise we will um
hey addict before we get started uh
what's your one player
um
i actually was playing a little bit more
of forza horizon but now
i think i'm uh pretty fours it out i've
played a decent amount of it so i think
i might like move on to
i know i dropped
phoenix point i don't know if you know
what that is it's like a turn-based game
but i think i might go back to it
because i just finished um that echo
generation and i really enjoyed that so
you know might go ahead and move on to
something new but what have you been
playing hustle
well
as you know
i kind of picked up a super nt so
i've been playing a variety of super
nintendo games we're playing um
super mario i've been playing y'all been
playing aladdin hey hey listen listen
aladdin and turtles in time aged well
aladdin a latin by capcom mind you this
joint i used well boy like it's still
still cool the controls is tight and um
you have the samsung ks8000
yes
so i completely because i have that
television as well i completely forgot
that you had to put the game in game
mode in order for like the latency and
stuff to like
you know
to be there so also you won't experience
any latency
man i completely forgot because i
haven't gamed on the television then
yeah i used
i use the game on this monitor
oh yeah so it was one of those things
and um
i don't know i don't know i'm gonna have
a i'm gonna have some type of review
about the super nt let's just put it
this way spoiler alert i am super
impressed with the with the price point
and everything and everything that it
offers is super dope um i will be
playing super nintendo games but
tomorrow i'm going to be playing four to
five
for the horizon five because i finally
get a chance to get two i didn't get it
early so we game passing that one up
y'all be game passing it up
yeah see
i i i've been really enjoying you know a
lot of the stuff that you get in the
game pass i actually there for a while i
was just doing the game pass on xbox and
he recently i'm like you know what let's
broaden my horizons hustle let's let's
get more stuff so i i i i opened up to
that ultimate and got access to the pc
uh game pass that i was playing some age
of empire man i was playing some age of
empire and uh people are already making
comments about your background uh so
yeah i feel like you chose that
background for a reason
i definitely did we'll get to it would
you would you like to speak about what
happened
yeah so i guess uh we we we could talk
about that so this is what happened guys
like i was on the attic show minding my
own business
and then
you know someone bought
um someone bought something in the
merchandise and for those who don't know
when you buy merchandise it pops up on
the right of the screen so i was like
you know what people have been wanting
me to play
these old games before i was born these
old crusty games before i was born these
games ain't nobody talking about unless
you unless these old-fashioned gamers
bring them up so i was like you know
what if you guys really want me to play
this game i'm gonna see i'm gonna see
what what what what you about i'ma see
it
so then what ended up happening is i
went ahead and said yo if you guys buy
five things of merchandise
i will
for uh i will stream one of these old
games and i let king pick the first one
so i don't know what happened but people
pulled up
uh people were buying three to four
shirts people was buying two peop like
it was ridiculous it was the most shirts
we've ever sold in that short amount of
time
so after we bought the first five i was
like you know what i might as well just
go straight in for it so i was like if
you for every five
i will play another game
so then
it ended up
ended up blowing up more from there man
i ended up seeing crazy stuff going on
and then before you know i'm playing
ninja gaiden and then before you know
i'm playing shinobi and then before you
know it i'm playing battle toads
like
i think you forgot one i think you
forgot one which one uh apparently
ghouls and ghosts are ghouls and goblins
i'm thinking super ghouls and goblins on
super nintendo but i think they want you
to play the one that was on sega
attic
all i'm saying is when you stream all of
this stuff
just make sure that you you give me the
heads up so i can make sure i get my
front row seat i'm gonna get my popcorn
i'm gonna get my patron i might have a
good old time because
hey look
it's not that those games are hard
they're just super irritating you won't
know what i mean but the respawning
enemies
you're gonna have fun but if you beat
demon souls you can be ninja gaiden
like if you
let's be real here what happens
if i beat these easy
i i don't think they'll do that but what
happens if i beat these easy
what happens if you beat that easy
absolutely nothing i mean hey you get a
round of applause for me yeah that ain't
no big deal you know i mean like no no
no i don't i don't think that you'll be
that easy because
it's gonna get to a point the way like
if one of those games i don't think any
of those games have a password system
and they don't really do checkpoints
like that so when you game over that's
it
yeah i have a feeling about the struggle
one of the reasons
yeah one of the reasons i think i'm
going to struggle because i'm not used
to playing those type of games
i mean so
i'm not going to give you no advice
you'll pick it up it's not like if you
can beat all of them other games on all
these hard difficulties they call you
the difficult game conqueror for a
reason
yeah you'll pick it up but it's it's
really not that difficult
look man all i'm saying
is that people want me because because i
know what's going to happen hustle i
know it's going to happen right now
people are going to say when i play that
two and a half hours people are going to
be like why are you getting off why are
you not playing it anymore look man that
game's got two and a half hours to
impress me
if it doesn't in that two and a half
hours it's off it's over it's done
and and i'm saying two and a half has in
mainly two two to two and a half hours
and if you guys keep going at me i might
go to one and a half to two to two and a
half hours oh man come on man you're not
gonna do full like weapon well oh
okay i thought he's gonna do four like
that's what i'm four that's what i
picked that's what i picture that's what
i picture when you say you're gonna
stream the game i figured you you go
four hours or whatever it is
look you'll enjoy them
um and goblins expectations man i mean
look goose and goblins in particular you
you'll definitely enjoy that game
so you're gonna like the power ups and
stuff what's up you know what we're
gonna do since people want to talk about
this we'll go over these games real
quick
so uh here's
ninja gaiden uh for the nes didn't he
isn't that what i'm playing for the nes
heat heat by the way so here's ninja
gaiden for the nes
this is the the dawn since they want me
to play
uh so
i hold up i gotta change up everything
real quick it's just like i i i don't i
don't think i'm gonna really have
too much
of uh you know i'm gonna i do think i'm
gonna struggle but i don't think it's
gonna be as like serious as people be
people be acting like you know like
there's no way i'm gonna be able to beat
it and i i don't
i don't think that's the case now that i
could rage and never beat it that's for
sure but i don't think i like there's no
way i can beat it so here's the age of
gaiden here's the game that king david
has me wanting to play
ninja gaiden on the nes with no deaths
uh i'm not doing the no death challenge
so you know here's the game he wants to
play which uh it's 40 minutes long
apparently if you beat with no deaths
uh so you know it looks like like a 2d
kind of like the old mega man style
games i don't know but you know so we
got the ninja gaiden uh what else did uh
it did uh
the next one was uh shinobi wasn't it
yeah you know which is a really on sega
genesis that's a really good game like
yeah i i remember me and my brother we
beat that game like that that game was
fun like i don't that's one of the ones
that i don't think that after that like
two hours or whatever i don't think
you'll stop playing that i'll be honest
with you that one's really good
is this it
because this looks kind of suspect fam
just oh it's revenge of shinobi so
that's the wrong one
uh i'm not sure what you're typing on
the thing but it's a revenge issue
though because yeah but i'm looking at
it then revenge of shinobi
oh what if you guys got me in what if i
got myself into man
hey that's fire hey look i am a giant
maybe you want to buy a sega genesis
just through the battle
oh yeah i'm there for that stream you
apparently you guys are there for all
the streams
well do you have a rare replay because
uh you can play uh yeah i do i do have
yeah
battle toes is on that so you can
actually play through uh only on your
xbox
yeah so as you can saw the uh
the stuff that they got me going off
right now and we'll see you know um
the first stream will be this friday
uh so we'll see how that goes
uh and you know i don't think like i'mma
like hate it or anything like that i
made dream daddies and entertaining so
like it's it's it's
i'm definitely going to uh give it mile
on that man
so all right
i got one added you could keep your i
got one all right because we ain't going
in anymore
x-men for nes no it's not happening
so all right let's let's go ahead and
get into the show man let's go into the
show first thing i want to talk about
hustle
is i do think
there is a huge speculation going on
with the industry right now with
community in general talking about
games as a service of whether or not
it's good or bad for the industry so
tell me your perspective on games as a
service games
my perspective on it it's not cool i
don't really
find value
into putting bread into something
all the time see i find value when
putting money into like a service like
game passed away there's a ton of
different games that i can play be
whatever
one game that i'm on
that you just pay into like
you maybe maybe you don't have to pay
into these games but like one one game
in particular that i'm just like grand
theft auto 5. to me it's dope but i
played and beat the game right there's
no way i'm buying the micro transactions
those little micro bucks just to run up
in the casino and all that i can't do it
and i know it's not mandatory but i
don't i don't like that direction i'll
say this man and you know the gaming
industry can still strive and survive if
you make a good game like i know that
the cost of games and all that had went
up and everything and i know that it's a
business and you got to make money but
if you make something like the last of
us part one right super mario let's say
odyssey or whatever it is that they're
making you can still make money hand
over fist if the game is good so good
games will always sell this whole games
is a service thing you know what it
feels like to me
you know what i feel like it feel like a
lot of it is like incomplete
like
you look at a game like hitman right the
most recent hitman that came out that
was like seasonal stuff but i think you
paid for it once and that was it
this game games of the ser games as a
service like that type of structure to
me is like all right we give you a
little something
but you gotta pay to get this other
thing and you gotta pay to get this
other thing you gotta pay to get these
weapons they're already charging you for
everything else the wazoo anyway man i
ain't with it i'm not rolling man there
and for real the sooner they gone the
better on consoles at the very least i
don't play on mobile if they want to
deal with that on mobile they can deal
with that but the sooner that's gone the
better in my opinion
here's how i feel about games as a
service
i do feel like
it is reaching into things it shouldn't
be in
but i don't think it's a bad sir i don't
think it's about structure it depends on
what's done with i do think that
as much as people don't like something
like gta 5 online because it's stunted
the progression of making gta 6.
i don't necessarily think that we should
put the blame on games as a service
that's just them not wanting to make a
six
okay because games as a service people
like my brother my cousin timmy like
they love that game and i don't think
you would get the same support
and the same uh amount of fun that
you've had throughout the years
if it didn't wasn't as a games as a
service like i think the issue is
people are trying to make games as a
service at everything
i think that's the issue
and i think that we need to remedy that
like you know putting marvel as a game's
disservice there's no reason to do that
and i think that is the biggest issue
that we're having here in terms of
people putting job stuff into uh into
games that has no business being there
stuff like destiny that makes sense
all right this is what we do about the
chat um do i have
if you guys have any what are we doing
it's just p people with no lies
look lady fox fire i get up anyone that
says pegasus nation up out of here like
like no
no timed out get them all up out of here
if you guys got a wrench get them up out
of here because
like this is the toxicity that we always
talk normally i let this stuff go
normally i let the stuff go but i'm not
letting this go
like
there is no reason to be this extra do
you realize how much time it took them
to go make multiple different accounts
and switches
how the world are we getting we won't
and what's funny is like if you would
look at the
if you would look at the actual topics
there's not even really xbox topics here
so like there's no reason to post
pegasus nation and stuff like that like
you know
different like i've had people pop in
and like joke around pegasus nation
stuff but
they are being extra in here right now
like extra like it's one thing to come
in here and joke around and then like
you know i pop a joke or two at you and
then we move on but these people are
making other accounts
to spam like imagine and what's funny is
they're probably laughing behind this
computer screen like they're winning
something when you ain't winning nothing
you ain't like though you you're
literally not winning anything the only
thing you're doing is making your
community look pathetic
and that that's just how it is like do
you think the people who are doing that
uh you know the whole uh
pegasus nation stuff do you think that's
what they envisioned when they made
something like that they don't want you
going around people's chat spamming them
with stuff like let's let's be real here
man let's stop this nonsense like come
on man look at that xbox station said
achievement nation no let's not
entertain it man let's entertain it
i have uh addressed it so like i said if
you see
if you see that nonsense in the chat and
you know that it's nonsense get them up
out of here don't don't
don't
time them out get them straight up out
of here i don't want them collecting
gold i want to collect 200 the funny
thing hustle
is they're in here trying to
trying to
to troll us
they're getting my attention right up
because they're sitting in here spamming
if i don't stop them they're getting my
viewers shove up because they're coming
here with multiple different accounts so
that's giving me views every time they
do it you're not doing anything man
you're not doing anything
but you know let's get back on to the
games as a service thing
indeed i honestly feel like there's a
lot of games that can use the games
i thought the head-to-head fighters
could use games as a service you know
and what capacity though just just in in
the model it's like you know like you
don't necessarily uh you know kind of
like how killer instinct was where you
know you get in the game for free and
you buy the actual controller the the
actual stuff that you want you know what
i'm saying like you don't have to
go in
it's it just makes the the bar to enter
that that that game a lot better and
that's what i feel like you know it's
something that needs to be done is i
think we need more of that like maddens
do you think mans need to come out every
year the way they are do you think 2ks
need to come out the way they are every
year
of course now but i want to go back to
that fighting game thing because i had a
couple of questions so with the killer
instinct thing
that if i remember they gave it to you
for free and i think you only had two
fighters but if you wanted everything
unlocked you paid the full retail price
correct
i what killer instinct
to my knowledge because i didn't play
killer institute but i know like a
little bit how that good like chad if
there's anyone in the uh chat that play
killing i think that was a free to play
yeah let me know it's just you can you
can buy you can buy package
to get is like a lot of the characters
going into it but i do think
the actual game was a free to play
yeah well
if you're gonna do it that way all right
i get it cause cause i do remember i'm
playing killer instinct and it was the
blue dude with the sword and it was
green girl orchid i remember that
remember those two
my my thing with that is you know
as you know as you can tell by my
background i'm old
i'm from the old school you put that up
there for a reason i had nothing to do
with this video man i no i know i know
but i definitely uh you know i'm old
like listen so when it comes to like
different like
i knew something was up with you when i
when you joined
the zoom and you had your green screen
up i was like that's not like uh hustle
what's going on there well it was two
things i didn't feel like cleaning up
behind me and i said you know what we're
gonna mess with addicts a little bit but
um no no when it comes to the fighting
game model in particular the reason why
i think that's detrimental to it is
because you have a game like marvel vs
capcom 2 which has over 50 fighters in
it now you don't start with 55 i think i
think you start with like half of that
i think you might start with 30. i'm not
exactly sure but you start with like the
bulk of the starter characters and the
more you play the game what you do is
you get in-game currency so you can go
to the shop and you can you know that's
how you can buy a can and
akuma and all those other different
characters that were hidden before you
can actually i think you can buy stages
and i know you can buy different outfits
as well
the last thing we need for something
like that is like uh you know that type
of
games as a service model because they're
gonna charge you for everything at that
point i much rather just play the game
and then and not have to play the game
50 hours just for like half of the
content i don't want to have to play
that game for 100 hours to get all of it
i want to play the game naturally
progress everything um i don't know if
you remember but remember jason schreyer
had a little comment about super smash
brothers ultimate when it first came out
was like he said i'm here to just unlock
the characters and you just buy him and
that's it and a lot of people was on his
neck about that so now that that that
games is a service like the model itself
i ain't winning man i
okay okay let's because i don't think
that is games as a service like the uh
the shortcut stuff i i do think that
when it comes to like being able to
because kids who's notorious for like
anything he plays if he's struggling he
wants to buy like he wants to put his
actual money in there and back up that
truck and get that currency that's in
the game do you like you know uh perfect
examples assassin's creed
uh you know they got a lot of uh
shortcuts in that game
i honestly think shortcuts and like paid
win models are different
uh depending on how they're done like
shortcuts such as battlefields the old
battlefields i don't know what they do
in the current ones because i've kind of
dropped off battlefield but they used to
have it to where you can have shortcuts
in you know the engineer class shortcuts
in these uh the the uh the health class
i can't remember the medic class back
then so i don't consider that as pay to
win i do consider that as like one of
those things where you know
it's still at the end of the day you're
just unlocking stuff fast you're not
necessarily to me a pay-to-win model is
getting something that is not accessible
in the game
but you're getting it because you're
putting in money
does that make sense it makes sense i'm
but i'm always going to be against that
because if it's if you can pay for it
that means you can probably unlock it in
the game
and if you and i guess maybe that's what
i'm worried about too like if
if you got something that's exclusively
paid for
like you know i don't know if you
remember but you know gamestop used to i
mean yeah gamestop used to do that but
like the little dlc packs how to how you
can go in and reserve a game early and
get like an exclusive skin and all that
i i always hated stuff like that because
like maybe i just want to naturally like
progress to get something
like in the game but like not but that
that the game is a service thing man i
i'm not gonna be able to do it and i
play battlefield
one
this whatever's out now i think it's
battlefield five
that i play i didn't feel the need to
like put no money up for that
in fact i didn't even know you could do
that until you told me you know one of
the biggest things i've always hated
that the industry did was loot boxes
like i felt like when loot boxes and
like any type of loot generated content
like you know where you open the cards
up in 2ks and well i think that's madden
ultimate i don't play those sports games
like that but i felt like that was a
loophole and that was a gate entry that
once that gate opened
other publishers went wild with the same
gate you know what i'm saying like
it's just like i do feel like
i'm glad that there's a little bit of a
of a of a step going on in the industry
where some of the governments are trying
to stop that
because
i do think that's an issue um i think
that there are some people that do it
right
at first remember it used to be
everything and then they used to be just
cosmetics but to be hustle is it me or
is it just like i'm getting tired
if if i want to have my character look
fire you gotta you gotta pull your card
out like
like i'm getting tired of that like i
prefer the thing to where
how destiny does all right so like how
for those of you because i know a lot of
you hating ass destiny players in that
chat so this is how destiny functions
and i know some of you play destiny but
they have events and what how it goes is
uh you have certain things in the events
that you were able to get and you could
only get in that event
until the next event
i want stuff like that how halo's doing
i like how halos do where the season
passes
the only way to get the stuff in that
season pass is to get this uh is to
actually grind in that season pass you
can't like someone that literally just
pulled up can't just pull out their card
and get the the skull out of nowhere
because that's not how they're wanting
that kind of uh marketing thing to go
they want that to be a little bit more
natural
and that's what i want
yeah and that's how it should be though
and that's how it should have been um i
made the comparison for marvel vs capcom
2. um it was one of my favorite fighting
games of all time uh marvel vs capcom
origins which was on the ps3 which was
marvel super heroes and mark versus
capcom 1.
every time that you like there's certain
objectives i think you were saying how
you were unlocking different things in
the game it's pretty much the same thing
and they were doing that back then as
far as like you'll get like certain
points for like different key art for
like you know mega man captain america
et cetera et cetera for different
characters and stuff like that instead
of you paying for it like they made you
play the game to unlock it and like that
to me was always like super dope the
only like drawback to something like
that is let's say if you have to play
five matches online in the game ain't
popping no more once you get it like
it's just like different little
drawbacks to that but there's always
ways around that too but no that but
that's how i should have been like but
and i've always said that like i've
softened my stance on like the whole
cosmetic thing because i understand that
people got to make money but if we're
being real if your game is good and you
promote it correctly
then like then you'll have something
like a ratchet and clank sell a million
and however long it was returned even
though people said it quote-unquote
flopped myself included you'll still
have it do like half a million for you
know a new ip and all that you as long
as your game is good and the promotion
right you don't have nothing to worry
about
i agree uh it's like i said in terms of
games as a service i just want
games as a service to be restructured a
little bit i i do think it has a place
i'ma be real i do think it has a place i
do think certain games uh are better as
the games as a service than they were
before
uh for instance like you know game like
destiny game i think halo is going to
work as a good games as a service
because
those have
massive expanding universes and i feel
like if you get like the thing is those
out the gate we need
the base game being enough content to
keep the average gamer happy people like
me i got to be real can't count people
like me because i'll blaze the [ __ ] out
of that content so like as long as you
keep the average gamer happy i think you
will be fine now obviously you got
people like me complaining because you
know you don't give me enough content
i'm gonna complain regardless i'm
probably going to complain even though
if there's nothing to complain about
i'll find something
and i think that's the biggest issue in
terms of games and services like
having a complete game at launch and
then supporting it through a games as a
service model afterwards
i mean like well i stayed in my opinion
earlier but i do have a question i do
have a question
what game would benefit
from it like what game would what are
some games that you would
could really think that you could that
could possibly benefit from games as a
service because you know i'm against
that man
from it i honestly do and truly feel
like carol instinct gained from it it
was uh one of the most popular uh
fighters when it was up when microsoft
was supporting it which if any of you
from microsoft watching this please give
these people killer instinct like i
don't even care about that game i won't
be real with you it's gonna be one of
those things where if you put it at e3
i'm gonna be flaming you because i saw
that i didn't want to see it but i
definitely understand why people want it
just because i don't want it i can
understand that there's a huge
demographic of people that do want it
just know i'll get you're going to get
the smoke from me when you announce it
but
it's going to be one of those things
where i think you're going to be more
beneficial
especially game pass like game pass is
supposed to be as diverse as possible so
let's get that head-to-head fighter in
there because to me how so i don't do i
had to have fighters at all but i think
microsoft pretty much has no influence
in that market whatsoever and i do think
they need to do something to broaden
that market a little bit but you know i
i think that game i think destiny has
has really gained from the games as a
service i think overwatch a lot of
mainly multiplayer games you know what
i'm saying like i think people get upset
when
they try to do certain things with
single player like marvel avengers
they were kind of really
didn't outriders
they they even tried to come out and
said it wasn't as games as a service
remember that
it's just like when you play the game
why is this not a games as a service
when this feels such like a games as a
service game
and i i think that's the biggest issue i
think that you know it needs to make
sense people don't need to just do it
for no reason i i do think that
ubisoft's gotten really bad on it like
ubisoft wants to make everything do a
games as a service and it's just like
look like
you can make
the rainbow six sieges like i don't
necessarily think ghost recon should
have been a games as a service but i
digress i don't know uh
for honor was a good games as a service
uh that's what he picks legends is a
good games as a service
so so that surprised me because i didn't
know that that was a game as a service i
like that game too
it's a free-to-play game i would
consider it a games as a service because
you get into it at low entry and you buy
everything with every everything else
you can earn in-game currency but it's
it takes a minute so like i feel like
there's certain games that could do it
the issue is the industry needs to be a
better judge of what is a good game to
try it with and what's a bad game to try
it with and i think when you take
you know
popular single-player franchises that's
been throughout the years and you try to
throw in some type of games as a service
stuff people are going to get upset with
that and i don't think you have any
right to not think that they're getting
let me give you a good example
this was a huge success but i was pissed
final fantasy 14 and 11.
so i come through here my whole life
waiting for another final fantasy man
and it's multiplayer online game so i
have every right to be upset
i don't want to play this multiplayer
stuff i want to play stuff that i want
to play
but at the end of the day some do
some do really help them uh you know we
got a five dollar super chat from
uh
man how do you pronounce this man's name
so
let me try and then you correct me let
me try it okay and then you can correct
me uh the saphenic x initiative i
definitely butchered it it is okay
i'm okay with butchering your name man
you might not be okay with butcher your
name but at this point i'm okay with
butchering your name uh he said what a
uh he fight all the super chat what
about the tell or
dean nod style oh no no he says what
about telltale or don't nod style oh
donut i don't think that's games as a
surface i don't know i'm
that's
because like okay so i'm not too too
familiar because i'll always wait for
like life is strange and all that i'll
wait for the complete package to come up
before i buy it
um do you pay for those separate or is
it just do you pay for it in one shot
you can pay you can pay for it all at
once but they come out individually i
consider that more episodic games not
necessarily games as a service because i
feel like at games as a service they
intend on supporting it throughout a
couple years
so i i feel like that is the difference
between the games as a service and an
episodic game episode of games i love
them
but they ended up crashing the whole
genre ended up crashing uh that's my
difference i i i know
maybe we have different
phrases and what we think is game
services what's not as games as a
service but in terms of just that that's
what i feel like as a games as a service
i don't necessarily think stuff that you
know they're doing i actually really
enjoy um
the super massive games hustle did you
play uh the last one
no i haven't
no i haven't had to me and kid smooth
played that we might have to play that
man that's a fun game uh madame
uh madam media it's the people
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh that might be a big skip because i
haven't everyone like until dawn like
that but i know i know
man you know what's funny until dawn's
probably my top five of my favorite
playstation 4 games really i love that
game that was such a good game
uh hold on hold on real quick it's a
seafood poetic i believe i got that
right uh x initiative uh is the other
1886 in your um top five
no no it probably ain't because you're
like is that's right
i didn't play that game
you okay well look if you find it used
some ways like five hours long or
whatever that game is really good and
you know what's funny just tell you that
yes i was defending
ultra 88 order
1886. there's videos of me on my channel
defending that game
it was good because i don't know if you
was like really active in the youtube
stuff back then
when order 1886
came out but
that game was getting roasted that game
was getting roasted alive
no i saw that but it always it bothered
me because i know who you talking about
and it's the bigger guys who i saw roast
that game i'm like yo did y'all even
play that because i played it i played
it much later and i'm like this ain't as
bad
excuse me this ain't as bad as people
like putting on man they was capping
there's a whole lot of cap for that game
yeah um you know i i guess
how it goes is
people take subjective stuff like for
instance i have a scenario where i
actually have a video on my channel
saying ign is taking their time
reviewing destiny rock by rock
and
fast forward five years destiny's
probably the most game i've ever played
like
in history so it's just like look like
sometimes you do got to try these games
you know if it wasn't for cognito i
never would have played destiny and i've
had so many good experiences from
destiny so you know we're going to go
ahead and get off the games as a service
thing because i think we kind of you
know explained it uh hustle's completely
against it uh a hundred percent against
it i do think that it has a place in the
industry but i do think that we need to
define better games to do games as a
service
all right let's talk about odor's ring
man elder ring or uh alden ring i think
it's called elden right l didn't ring
yes
so
did you see the gameplay man did you see
the gameplay
i did i did and uh let me be the first
to tell you why and like it i like it
nah no and if we if we listen really
closely we can hear erica cursing me out
in the background on twitter we can
definitely hear eric cushing me out
listen the demon souls type format that
neo-type format that dark souls type
format and i know you know where it's
coming from i ain't never really rocking
with it
you saw me try to play the
demon souls on the ps5 it didn't turn
out too well for your boy um one of the
things that i do well one of the things
that i absolutely love about the actual
like game itself is like the characters
or like the character design rather it
looks really good and it's not like
how can i explain this i don't know if
the dark souls demonstrates i don't know
if the bloodbornes i don't know if those
games are naturally like
dreary in you know in in like the design
but this one looked like it had sunlight
it was like it looked like all vibrant
and everything it looked like really
cool like if you really can play that on
a 4k tv and on your ps5 pc what have you
then you you'll be doing yourself a
favor if you do that i love like the
actual character design the enemy design
but i've always liked the enemy design
in those types of games i just don't
like the gameplay itself
there i think there is a three-player
co-op in it as well
and if that's the case then i'm gonna
need you to help me i'll be right back
if i can get some help i'm gonna keep it
real with you because like i know that's
not my cup of tea and all that um
let me let me ask you something about uh
dinosaurs about that type of genre um do
it do you think that eldon ring is going
to be like demon souls because then
demonstrates when i did play it
the enemy placement they didn't move at
all they didn't change they didn't
switch up anything like i knew what
enemies i knew those two skeletons were
going to drop in the big pick and on
that first level i knew where the other
two well that's been all their games
bloodborne okay so that's
so this will probably be the same man
i'm cool with with that type of
memorization because it really does help
me remember like i know that you're here
i know that [ __ ] is so it gets easier
over time
but it's just
all right look
i don't like to die i'm not gonna cut on
the cheek code either but i don't like
to die man like and and i know with a
game like that i'm gonna die over and
over and over again like i
i'm cool on that it looks fun though
i watch you streaming if you stream it
but i it that ain't for me man yeah
that that is not for me it looks but it
looks cool like i saw like the the audio
it's always like the music and
everything how they got to like the
the dreary voice whatever that is
narrating i like stuff like that so
there is a lot to appreciate
when it comes to the actual game itself
like it looked fun it's just not for me
it looked like it's you know what it's
like it's too slow for me does that make
sense like it's like
it's like you want a one-on-one fight
with whatever npc that you run up on you
might get double standing triple team
but i only seen like the one i only seen
like the most and most three i'm on
screen together and i saw that
excuse me i saw that extremely big
dragon that was coming there i saw it he
stabbed him in the eye and all that i
love how gruesome it is too like that's
that's the other thing i was watching it
at work today i said this thing you know
it's it's joining hard man i like i like
it but
uh that i listen listen if i about to
join i'll be wasting 70 dollars
i'll be real oh so you completely
against it man i'm not well hold on i'm
not against the genre itself and i may
even buy that one like i did return all
right because i want the genre to like
live on because that type of game has a
place for people
um we won't get into it but the game
doesn't need easy mode to stand in the
third i'm not taking the crap on nobody
who thinks that but they don't they
don't need all that that game needs to
stay true to itself because like it
looks fun but it's it's just a little
too much for me and i'm okay with
admitting that
i guess when it come to me
is
i do i i don't difficult gate keep like
i i do feel like if they want if if the
developer wants to make easy modes and
stuff like that as long as it doesn't
mess with the core
base i don't really care if it's there
or not if that makes sense to you
uh so i guess like in my
standpoint
that doesn't matter to me like i'm
looking at it now i'm having it play in
the background while while i'm talking
but i i like what i saw like what i
liked the most about what i saw is it
really feels like they're trying to do
something different you know what i'm
saying like it feels like they're trying
to have a different take on something
and this is one of those scenarios where
like look like people keep asking
companies to do something different to
try to to change it up a little bit and
when companies do change it up i don't
want to hear one person saying that oh
this is this just doesn't feel like dark
souls or this doesn't feel like first
off his name's eldon ring it's not dark
souls it's name's elder green it's not
bloodborne like you know and what's
funny is the same people that want these
kind of experiences they are also
saying that uh you know we want new
experiences but they're asking for a
remake of bloodborne you know what i'm
saying so it's like look like let's try
it out uh i do like what i saw i the the
spirit thing was kind of interesting to
me like it's kind of interesting how
that went i i did like the random dragon
that was just running around the map i
don't know if that's like like a
scripted thing but oh my god i hope so i
hope that that script did because
it felt like that thing's going to kill
a lot of people that that that character
design was jack gangsta i like that um
well you know this is from software they
got their own genre a game so like
they shouldn't switch nothing up like
imagine how tough it is well first of
all imagine how tough it is for what we
do right because being with content
creators we always have to find a way to
put the content out but we also have to
find a way to be innovative i have to be
different from you just like we have to
be different from cognito et cetera et
cetera right
imagine that like they came up with
their own genre a game and it's stuck
like is it came with
demon souls or was it dark souls
whatever the first one was it came out
what yeah
they've done stuff before demon souls
but that was one of the first like big
like games that they had
so you know
i i i'm very curious on you know how
they're going to
to do stuff you know i just i just want
authenticity i just want new stuff and i
think we're going to see it man i really
do i think that
they've been man that really did well
with that playing in the background i
was kind of wondering if that was going
to make it like glitch or something but
yeah i'm looking at it as we're talking
yeah it look cool yeah all right
all
right
so we got a five dollar strip shot from
um flame
reject eldon ring return to jedi fallen
order at least it has characters and
platforming don't even at me
everyone at flame in the chat everyone
if you are in that chat at that man
don't come at me with that nonsense i
look i'm joking flame look at the end of
the day
i understand where you're coming from
and i think jedi fall in order does that
type of formula very well
actually shout out to one of my deaf
friends man he went over there he's
working over there now he used to be at
three four three he moved over there uh
so you know yeah shout out to him and i
i think that jennifer was a fantastic
game it really was i really enjoyed it
especially the end i don't know if uh
did you ever beat that no sir it was a
little too much for me so
kid smooth beating hustle
hey hey listen i'm a worse gamer in the
kids movie you see how i got a problem
saying that
don't bother me
at all
i just i just personally feel like that
it's a great formula and i want i
actually got really jumped on because i
said i wanted fable to have
dark souls like comments don't do that
man nah i said i wanted fave would have
dark souls like not not hardcore
but i wanted it to to have that feeling
of fighting in the dark souls kind of
formula you know what i'm saying like
i'm not saying i want them to like like
kill me over and over again but i do
like the
aspect of having that type of combat in
a fable like game
uh you know maybe bounties like imagine
like having a very soft form of that
dark souls like combat where inside is
it's not as punishing
having that in there and i feel like
that would really help
a lot of stuff in terms of combat
because i mean there's a lot of
different types of combat but we can all
agree i'm saying for the most part we
can mostly agree that that dark souls
like combat evolved that action
orientated game significantly i do it's
it's arguably to say that maybe games
like neo would never have been around
without that type of game
oh for sure yeah um dark souls was
definitely the pappy
the innovator the originator as it were
no no yeah because erica tried to get me
to play it not brought neo i bought him
on sale but um erica had tried to get me
to play it and i was like eh
and then you know when second row first
came out i said i just wanted to see how
far i can get in the second row that
wasn't for me either man again smoothie
beat that too just shout out smooth man
that look
you gotta know your limits at it you
gotta know your limits
listen i think what i'm gonna end up
doing i feel assuming i'll run into the
money
i'll buy that game and i'll give it away
to somebody like you know just because i
want the dare to get that sale what's up
i just want to point out that i've beat
all these games oh sir
i didn't beat demon souls yet i haven't
beat demons yet uh i need because i cuz
i've been wanting to play it but i've
been really wanting to stream and i feel
like that's a really good game for me to
stream so i didn't want to like waste my
uh
streaming first impressions on that game
so i can keep it in the chamber man
actually it's not even in the chamber
hey before you read that super chatting
before we move on i believe his name is
layburn88 i mean i can't see your name
because it's smaller pen i probably need
glasses falling order has an easy mode
and it's more accessible you're right
you're right worse from the worst like
at least something like that where it's
going to worse i'll cut the journal easy
and i don't know i don't get no shame in
it i cut that journal easy and just have
a ball like at that point but the
problem with easy mode is
sometimes easy is too easy like and it's
not even like it like is way too easy
like it's not it's not even like a thing
like you can play games on normal and
that's the new easy that's been floating
around which is the absolute truth but
if you put a game on easy like they
don't even put up a fight at that point
so i just i mean with with today is
current gen games with the game behind
me however hey
you might beat all them beaming souls
games but
hey look just don't slam your controller
down like that don't don't spike it
don't rob guard count don't slam it down
you have no idea that's all i'm saying
it is
i will be there i will be there for but
i don't want to derail it can you get
the super chat from flame please
we got to find out subtract from flame
okay addict i
kind of want a blend of chakra type
combat for the new fable have difficulty
options like fallen order through for
the noobs and that that's you know that
that's what i i was stating earlier like
i'm not a difficult like person where i
want to gatekeep difficulty because i've
always felt like when it comes to
gatekeeping um you know if if if the
developers want to put it in there let's
say
that's the only condition that i would
have it's like you know if someone came
to me and they asked me how you feel
about the subject i don't care if they
do it as long as the base game is done
first and then they go back and say okay
what can we do to make this easier for
people that don't really know this type
of game play you know what i'm saying
and you know there's a variety of
different reasons people can't play
those type of games i know for one kid's
move could be any these type of games
but once he dies once or twice it's a
rat like the rest of the stream is done
like he he's officially lost his mind
and uh you know
so uh
so i i think i just saw that because i i
sorry i apologize i wasn't looking at
the chat uh saifu
saifu that that's sifu
is seafood okay i will try to remember
that man if you're still in the chat man
you guys know how it is right i can't
pronounce stuff to save my life i just
can't i can't but you know i i
i probably were going to make
a
because i was talking last week about
the attic spotlight i'm actually in the
process of setting one up for halo
infinite so i might do and i i did one
for fable a long time ago but i think
now
the channel's grown to a lot more where
i can feel comfortable doing it now
okay so i think i might get people
together to do
a fable attic spotlight now i got to
figure out how i want to do it i might
re reach out to you hustle and find a
good way of doing it usually it used to
be like pretty much it would be a
podcast but every topic would be about
that game
so you know it sound dope to me it's
like a complete breakdown
yes and now
i'll talk to you behind the scenes about
something else you should probably
implement as well but we'll talk about
that all right so let's go ahead and
talk about the uh the reason why i'm
sure a lot of people are here i didn't
even know this is an issue hustle i'm
gonna be real with you i didn't know
this was an issue until now
but apparently
forza horizon 5
people are a little upset that
maybe
this game
got overlooked intentionally well not
necessarily intentionally that's a very
strong word uh over maybe getting
game of the year uh so first off my
question to you
is let's let's break down the way game
of the year is done in general where the
video games or awards are done um let's
do vgas because that's the most popular
vga's cutoff is like november something
like that eighth or
sometime in november
where
no thing after that day
can be counted towards game of the year
to me
november is a very popular date to
launch
some of the most popular games of the
year is it not
it is holiday season so so you need to
tell me next year
that's
starfield's automatically not getting in
to the the year because it's coming out
november 11th
yeah
yeah basically i don't understand how
that's not like how no one talks about
that
like you needed to tell me that like the
most popular month i would say october
november the most popular months for for
the most popular games that you know the
big triple a's generally try to launch
in those two months and you needed to
tell me for the second month which i
think november
is some of the the game like
uh elder scrolls skyrim came out in
november like some of the most popular
games have came out in november so you
made it a fallout 4 came out in november
i'm pretty sure so you mean to tell me
that these games just naturally get
left out
yeah um well because well the reason why
they do it is they got a certain cut off
there because whoever's
judging apparently they got to play the
game and they got to beat the game and
give some type of assessment on it by a
certain time
now i thought
because we remember we ran into this
with deb stranden and i thought the
cutoff date was like the 15th or
something i'm like yo we're talking
unfortunate this ain't i think they
actually deliberately
made an exception for death strategy
be careful addict be careful shout out
to john kelly
in the chat man if people know
what is the cutoff date for go ahead and
talk why uh talk about that i look that
up
yeah so
you know it when death stranding dropped
a lot of people was like yo is it going
to make the days they're not going to
make the day and i want to tell y'all
death stranding i know it came out in
november but i want to say
it was it was some type it was
controversial behind it because it was
so close to the deadline i think they
extended it then and they probably
shouldn't have
now
if if that is the case my memory might
be failing me you know i'm an old man
yeah i know this i'm not going to look
that up because it you know it's kind of
like not important
if wait by the sound of what you're
telling me addict it sounds like you
said forza was was snub
someone said that i don't know but it
right here it's telling me on here it's
november 19th
right yeah
so i was like i said this hadn't been
like mid-november i said don't this game
come out like so tomorrow
if it's november 19th and then forza is
definitely in the making all right so
that's a little bit better than what was
going around on twitter i don't know
where these people get this stuff uh you
know so let's talk about
the actual concept even november 19th
which is still a good amount of time and
i would say the majority of games would
come out by november 19th uh there are
a couple exceptions like halos coming
out december 8th but you know
me especially me and kid smooth have
like this real big you know using games
into december to die
yeah because i i'm not saying that they
put bad games in december i'm saying
that that's a weird time to have a game
is in december
so you know maybe they wanted it in
december because they still wanted to
hit that release window maybe that
yeah
i don't you know the whole game is in
the simple thing we're gonna get back to
the game awards thing in a minute it's
not bad now because you have you have uh
something like game pass nps now the way
you can just drop it in and you can just
play it at that type of leisure um
okay so november 16th or no okay it's
november 19th shout out to lebron in the
chat he said pearl um the game awards
website it's november 19th and yeah at
first you had me thinking that forza got
snubbed because they typically don't so
apparently the reason that people are
getting this confused is because it's
not the cutoff date it's when they send
their votes in
jeff grobb sent his in before the
deadline to make the dead
before the before the deadline to make
the deadline so i think what he's saying
is
he had to send his
his vote in to what he wants this that
and uh that to be in terms of what's
going on in the industry before
forza came out to make sure it got to
them before the game came out
before okay
so first off why are we doing stuff male
wise anyway like we never heard of like
like you mean to tell me
like i don't know how this goes let me
make that clear right now
addict don't know how none of this stuff
goes i'm speculating off someone that is
ignorant in the subject
so but since i got that disclaimer out
there let's talk
all right so
you mean to tell me that i can what i
can overnight something
to
[Music]
to um i can overnight something to
arizona but people can't get stuff to
california in the same amount timely
manner like like you mean to tell me the
people that run the vga can't pay for
overnight express scene like i just i
don't i don't like and i'm not saying
this is the the people who review the
games as well because i don't think it
is but this is one of those things where
the people who do the vga that whole
board if they have to do stuff by mail
they need to be hitting up ups yo
um i need to make a deal with you and
make sure we get this stuff in a timely
manner
like because to me first off
you know we're going to talk about here
in a second about how they even do that
because to me hustle the vga shouldn't
be told january or february
and it should be the calendar year of
the year before
you you know you're not wrong in saying
this i think the grammys
come on because well as you know eric
i'm like a big music here but i think
the grammys drops around that time too
and i think it's either right before the
super bowl right after super bowl anyway
it should be like i mean maybe
jeff got a schedule at that point in
time because that's when the sponsors
and them like put the bread up and
that's when he'll probably get the peak
viewership what have you because he's
competing with all the other stuff on
television super bowl grammys
emmys et cetera et cetera so he's
probably people competing well he's
definitely competing with that that's
probably why he has it in december but i
think
i think that that has to change at some
point because like you have to
like super smash brothers one of my
favorite games on switch probably my
favorite game on switch
and you had to pretty much wait a whole
like another year in order for it to win
best fighting game which is uh deserved
by the way which is what you didn't
deserve by the way but
it's
that that's that's a whole lot to deal
with and um if
um jeff grubb if grub had to send his
and you know had to send his votes in
early
just so he can get the stuff on time but
here's the thing
if he wanted to he could have
overnighted it and then she probably
just could have got reimbursed for it's
30 dollars over overnight something to
california matter of fact it probably
wouldn't cost that much money if we if
he has to do it that way if he has to
mail it in that way and he got to send
it overnight through postage and all
that
i say 30 dollars i sent off a graphics
card to one of my homies out in
california cost me 30.
that's costing you way more than like a
ballot would like because they do it by
weight so yeah like that's my only thing
that i don't make sense like i don't
understand how like
how people don't like overnight shipping
exists you know what i'm saying like so
like i don't see the thing is like we
need to get someone on the show that
knows how that process works
because i'm curious because i want to
tear that [ __ ] apart
hey this is what you this what you do
addict i mean y'all know him you know
you reach out to grub you know make sure
we catch you reach out to grove i'll
read it
you got a two dollar super chat from
flame did uh jeff forget about email
laugh out loud at wtf see the thing is
like
there is not anyone more genuine in this
industry than jeff grubb
and i think he's talking about the dude
from vgas he's not talking about jeff
grubb because he's saying he's talking
about jeff keller yeah that's joe i
don't know what jeff keeley would be
doing i don't like you know i'd love to
get him on ielts podcast iop i'd love to
get that man on iop i love you
regardless
how they do things that i think they
need to change things
i do understand
that it's like cognito said we need to
be grateful that we have something like
the grammys and something like the uh
whatever the tv shows and movies call
their stuff
so you know because you know for their
long time we didn't have a consistent
one man we really didn't like we had you
know something that was kind of weird
something that wasn't kind of weird but
now i do feel like we have a very
prominent contender in that process and
to my knowledge is it isn't the the vg
the video game war starting to do better
than the other stuff
it's
i oh you know that's that's tricky
that's the only trick because the time
that we leadership-wise like
yeah
yeah no yeah i know that because they'll
tell you that so many people are
watching over the world which is really
good for for the gaming for the game
awards because
i remember when they was on spike tv and
you might remember this too but when
they was on spike tv and they had those
awards it wasn't that they were bad but
you know they just wasn't they wasn't
hitting the same like they hit now so
you know by jeff taking that over and
he's like molten listen to its own this
is super good for him um
if it's competing with the grammys i'd
be surprised because you got hundreds of
millions of people that's that's a
really worldwide thing like then i know
i say worldwide when we talk about like
the game and stuff
yeah yeah but that that that music is on
a different level the movies is on a
different level like but the medium um
in gaming is growing like for sure and
we actually like see all of that like
it's dope to me if he can ever get it
like on like a cbs
then i think it will officially change i
i want to say it was on cbs before but i
think i think the game will officially
change yes sir so okay i'm looking at
now the grammy viewership rewards was
8.8 million viewers
it's embarrassing video game or
i haven't even clicked on this yet
hustle i have a feeling that the vgas
from last year is about to stomp the
[ __ ] out of that nut i don't know i
think so i didn't think i did not never
would have thought the numbers was that
low
uh it looks like
20 20 uh
last year 20
uh
december 10 20
is 83 million that's wow you know
yeah a year before that was 45 million
the weir before that was 26 million it
does look like that they they are
stomping the other ones man and you know
what that is like pulling up yeah yeah
they they pull it up like you know
that's why i'm saying like as bad as
some of the stuff
is
needs to be improved like we can be
honest on that like the vga isn't 100
good but it is to the point where i do
feel like there's a solid foundation
there and it can definitely
go up there's nothing else but to go up
and it's a really good
standpoint to celebrate gaming
i just feel like
in terms of what qualifies and what
doesn't qualify maybe a little bit of
how the system does itself in terms of
reviewing stuff maybe it needs to change
a little bit i don't know necessarily
i'm not for popular vote i know a lot of
people want popular vote in terms of
vgas i'm not for that because i don't
want call of duty and then winning every
year to some point there has to be a
curve so i'm definitely appreciated that
they do
go above and beyond to make sure that
that doesn't happen
like i love how they do it now like the
way like the audience us we're only
worth like 10 percent
that i feel like that to me is like
i feel like that we could be worth 15
percent like i think we should be worth
20 man we should be worth yeah because
we're 20 like i think
10 is kind of a slap in the face
i mean you know
it is what it is i mean you know but
again you don't want something like the
popular vote taking over because you can
get like a whole lot of like celeste
fans and celeste one of my favorite
games 2018.
we could have formed together like
voltron and god of war about the pink
and it wouldn't have been the right
thing to do because god of war is is
actually a better game than than
everything else that came out that year
so shout out to god of war no but i i
get it like i get it and i understand
i'm still a little surprised that the
the numbers you just told me because and
i'll tell you why those numbers are even
like that
um it's rumored
well speculated rather that with the the
grammys and the emmys and stuff like
that
that they had like a set of judges who
didn't really who wasn't really with the
times um especially especially with
music like it was it was it was getting
pretty bad people just got tired of
watching people really got tired of
watching so i can understand that so
when we had something like the game
awards pull up and it's everywhere on
youtube twitch what have you i think i
understand and then i get it like
i guess i'm just more surprised by it
because this is the stuff that i grew up
watching and there was no video game
awards back then like back when i was a
kid like when we were kids nah it wasn't
there none of that stuff was really
there like that so
by this new thing coming in and taking
over
um
i mean that's that's cool that's super
dope especially as far as it pertains to
what we do to be honest with you i think
the biggest issue that we're having when
it comes to the vgas the emmys and the
grammys the emmys is the tv and movie
one right
yes
so i think the biggest issue we're
having is a lot of these demographics
that watch
these type of things some of them are
split for instance a lot of the gamers
they're very connected to online so
they're more open to watching stuff like
that i think they're watching more
youtube and stuff so they're actually
knowing the video game awards exist
i don't think everyone that watches
movies is going to go watch the emmys or
the oscars you know what i'm saying like
so i think that's where you have the
split because you know video games we
can understand where something's coming
from and we know what's coming from and
we know
a lot of us know where to expect some of
these from and i think
the gaming industry in itself has
probably grown bigger than both of the
other ones combined
because it's definitely bringing it it's
bringing in way more money that's that's
for damn sure like that's not even close
like gta probably makes more money than
both of those just by itself like it's
mercy
yeah it's
oh man you know
games at 60 to get 20 dollars a pop
you know they're going they don't kill
them movies every time man
that's why oh wait real quick before
before we go on because i know we're
going to talk about forts and everything
and which weather should be gaming again
that
that's why like those numbers don't
impress me when people say oh well
gaming is the most um you know
it's much the most lucrative industry to
stand in there nah that won't impress me
because you got games at 60 a movie
ticket that cost you 20 at most
depending on you know what you do
depending on what type of theater you go
to
20 maybe 30 at most for a ticket so like
so stuff like that don't impress me what
would not make it more impressive that
was such a high entry to game it's so
lucrative and growing so rapidly because
like you could just go to a movie
theater besides the pandemic just pay a
little you know 10 to 15 to 20 depending
on where you live because here my my
tickets are only 10 bucks for him
i don't have like those big theaters
like you do i'd rather pay what you guys
pay because you guys get a way better
experience
but would it be more uh it's more
impressed that you have a lower entry
and it's still not overtaking the gaming
industry that has a higher entry
no and i'll tell you why because even
even though we may not be fans of it
necessarily call of duty right
you got something that you can spend 60
on and get 200 hours of enjoyment out of
i spent 60 on gears and got like 130
hours in it and that was well worth it
for me like you understand how much i
was playing that so that that one time
purchase
just went and went and it kept going
because i always had it what's up so do
you think that that might be why it's
growing so rapidly because
you know sure i just wouldn't watch the
eternals talked about it a couple of
times on twitter maybe a little bit to
cognito
and then it just slowly dies out because
you know that after effects not there
but you play something like call of duty
something i mean hell we we've we've
been playing we've been talking about
fours all week so like you know like and
that and i won't even think that that's
like
that that's not like the color of a halo
imagine when halo comes out how long are
we talking about that mother that thing
so that's free that's right do you think
that that might be one of the reasons
it's growing so much because it's always
in conversation because we're always
talking about it because the game's
always being played
yeah i mean and carla dooley and call of
duty and madden in particular come out
every year so you know you kind of know
what you get when it when it comes to
stuff like that um and again like you
said you want to go see the eternals
right are you going to go see the
internals i don't care how good it was
you probably won't go back and see it
for quite some time you'll probably wait
for the dvd to drive but you're not
going back to the movies
unless i was pulled somewhere unless i
was pulled somewhere to watch it by a
woman i never watched the movie twice
ever
like and i think the only movie i've
ever watched twice is one of the
twilight movies
um that's literally the only movie i've
ever watched twice i'm not really a big
fan of going back and watching a movie
twice
uh it's it's i think i almost did it for
the the ten rings that movie that just
came out
uh um you talking about um
the legends of the ten rings or
something like that yes that was a
fantastic movie and i almost went and
watched it twice
yeah i never got around to actually
going to watch it so let's let's go
ahead and and go up a little bit and
talk about
forza 5. all right so forza horizon 5k
i'm sure everyone in the chat knows
about it i don't expect a whole lot of
casuals watching my show unless you're
coming over from my facebook which uh
you know i apologize but you know so
let's talk about fours of five there's a
lot of people
that have
this
this thing
on what deserves game of thrones what
does not deserve game of the year uh
this has nothing to do with jeff keeley
this is just strictly something that i
see the community talking about so my
question to you hustle i i want a
question to you
do you think a racer deserves to be
nominated for game of the year
absolutely not
oh we're going to disagree on this okay
let go unless because well there's a
caveat to it for me
um typically the games that win game of
the year it's not that they aren't any
more or less deserving but one of the
things that that had they have in common
as opposed to what racing games a lot of
racing games don't have it's like a
story nah look i'm not saying a story
like the last of us even though that
would be kind of dope but like if if the
fast and furious like
movie franchise was a game and it was
pulled off right by like playground turn
10
could you really deny it at that point
if if the voice acting was on point at
the gameplay because the gameplay for
these games are already on point anyway
if they mixed it up a little bit can you
really deny something at that point if
it has a really good story like a lot of
people like i would say shooters are
boring to me i look at something like a
gears gears five right
you run you shoot whatever like kate's
or laura bailey's performance in that
you know in that game in particular is
like really stands out you really get
emotionally invested to the characters
something like forza i can't get
emotionally invested into a bmw i'm
sorry i can't do it i can't do it so no
so it
unless something changes with that story
or yeah i mean like you give me a reason
to care about it a racist will never win
game of the year
okay i don't care how fun it is it'll
never happen that'll never happen
i
i think it's a game it deserves to be
game of the year uh that deserves at
least have the chance of being game of
the year i brought this up on iop and
i'm curious in your opinion about it
what do you think about
obviously there's no way of knowing this
but it is weird
that almost every year
a game an indie game gets nominated for
game of the year
it doesn't matter how stacked that year
was
on any game almost every time gets
nominated for games a year do you think
that they're doing some form of system
where they're putting an indie game in
there to kind of give that scene
a bone do you think that's going on
behind closed doors
oh one thousand percent and that's hell
i figured that's why they did it like
you know independent games are
independent games a lot of people don't
like 2018 i go back to that celeste was
nominated for game of the year and it's
not that because that's one of my
favorite games yeah it's not that i
don't think that it didn't particularly
deserve it of course god of war won it
because it should have won it
but like just to have that look just to
have like the denomination to be like
now we see what you're doing you tip the
hat we tip the hat to you this game was
so good
i it was the standout in the field of
indy's that's why i was pushed here but
it's not going away no no that's that's
definitely a thing and um hey real quick
uh let me make sure i see you it's that
game play-doh don't get blocked in the
chat tetris
no story not a game don't get blocked in
that chat though don't get blocked in
that chat
forza does not deserve but overwatch
that wanted deserved it uh
hey come on
hey i'm not rolling by the way come on
the overwatch thing i wasn't in the
community back then so i don't know i
was i was cognito was very upset that
that happened oh no we we got a good
laugh at it go ahead
this is how i feel about in terms of
game of the year
i don't particularly think game of the
year necessarily means on what game was
better
i've always felt like if they were gonna
word it like that they would say best
game of 2021
just like they do the best best action
adventure the best racing of 2020 like
i've always felt like when i look at
game of the year it's what game pushed
the industry forward
i felt like overwatch did i felt like
last year as much as i didn't really
particularly like unchartered uh last of
us two in a lot of aspects of that game
that did uh it pushed it drastically in
how a game features like
i've always felt like in terms of a game
it's
what game made waves and not just was a
good good game you know what i'm saying
like
i felt like red dead 2 was a great game
but i don't personally felt like it it
caused waves
because it because a lot of the stuff
that was done in red dead has happened
before
uh you know and i mean
i think attention to detail is good i
will admit to that they have really good
attention to detail but i've always felt
like
game of the year needs to go to the game
that made the most waves that impacted
the industry the most that year and i've
always felt like it doesn't necessarily
mean that and i i get it
and i know some people are probably
going to disagree with me on that i feel
like
forza horizon 5
should definitely get the chance to be
and it's like i was bringing up the
indies the reason i bring up the indies
is because
let's say that they are naturally
wanting to make sure an indies and game
of the year every year so that means
something's naturally going to get
thrown out of it
because they had to make sure it was
room for an indie so instead of
nominating well i think there's five in
there every year there's five
nominations
uh either five or six yeah we'll say
five so every year
the illusion that there's five spots up
for nomination but it's really only four
because one of them is going to be an
indie and until i see a year where we
don't have an independent developer uh i
think last year you could
argue that it wasn't because technically
outer worlds
was on there and that's not but i do
feel like people considered outer worlds
an indie game still because microsoft
didn't interfere with that game is that
you get what i'm saying mm-hmm so you
know i get you
i i think that you know if if that does
happen i'm not saying that happens i
don't know what happens i'm just saying
in part of speculation and seeing what
happens throughout the years it's
convenient that every year there's some
form of indie game there
uh i do feel like sometimes the indie
games deserve to be there hades
perfect example that game probably in a
lot of people's mind deserve to win
and
but i don't think you need to have
because because i brought this up and a
lot of people got upset with this this
analogy that's it because i feel like in
a way that's setting some developers up
to fail
uh but you know saul brought up a good
point that
is that setting them up to fail because
they're going to get a lot more
spotlight how many people probably
bought celestio because it was on game
of the year list how many people
probably bought hades because it's on
game of the year list so they're getting
a lot of free promotion and being on
this but as far as the award itself
i do feel like they put a game up there
knowing it's not going to win you know
what i'm saying knowing that there's a
slim chance that it's going to take that
back
attic the difference between celeste and
uh hades
as opposed to four to five four to
horizon five four three two or one or
fourteen motorsport
those independent games had a story in
them
i'm telling you like this is one of the
only things that's like separating let's
let's break that down let's break that
up your story
so you think that a game has to have a
story for it to be considered
on that rival to be in the nominations
for a game of the year um
break that down a little bit more for me
i'm curious what you mean by that
well i'll say this the only thing that a
game like forza is missing is that like
because if we if we talk about
graphically
it's probably one of the better better
looking games like that racing games
always look good no matter how you
you know no matter how you put it racing
games always look good this is why they
show them why they show off new consoles
right uh let's see what else gameplay
and i played the last four to and i
remember playing folks in motorsport the
very first one so i played those before
the gameplay was on point i don't even
like racing games like that that game
play was on point uh sound design
i really feel like i'm in a car when i'm
driving like i really feel like i'm in
my charger when i'm driving the charger
in the last forza horizon on game pass i
really feel like that and that's that
ain't no cap my headphones are on and
all that i really feel like that what
else is missing i mean the music is the
music you know music is subjective but
the music is there as well whoever they
like get the license to that's
subjective
what's the only thing that is missing
addict
what's the thing that i didn't bring up
is it
look i'm not a racing fan but i will
admit to you that like
as far as racing games and and what i
remember is being a casual ass racing
fan throughout the years
is the only game that i remember having
a definitive story in terms of something
that i felt like was enough to make me
remember it to this day was need for
speed most wanted where you lost your
car you had to fight your way back up
the blacklist to take on the dude who
who who sabotaged your car at the
beginning of the game and took it so i
felt like that's a narrative
because you had cut scenes like the dude
literally sabotaged your car took your
car
and climbed up the blacklist with your
car
and then you and then he took his
friends with him like
so he took his girl he took he took the
girl if i remember right right yeah and
he took his friend ronnie in like
another person because they were the top
three blacklist members i remember
something like that and i do agree
that racing stories do need to evolve
and this isn't just
forza racing stories in general need to
evolve we got a five dollar super draft
from gamer by choice
say i love you gamer by choice because
you have a name i can pronounce
i love that you have a name that i am
very confident when i see that chat
super chat gamer by choice i'm confident
in reading it i don't think to myself oh
god i said yes i'm gonna read this super
chat because i know i'm gonna be able to
pronounce that name but anyway we got a
five dollar superchat from gamer by
choice
so if a game had a great story and the
gameplay is basically hitting a at cut
scenes then is that a game of the year
i'm pretty sure that's directed towards
you hustle
i said what i said listen the only thing
thoughts are missing is the story as far
as because it got everything else
together it's everything else is
together as far as i'm concerned man but
you know it'll never be that um
you we saw overwatch in 2016.
i got my thoughts on it i'm glad i
wasn't making youtube back then cause i
probably got canceled behind those
thoughts
i'll just say that we won't see nothing
like that happen again
because i think that people's voices are
too loud when it comes to that anyway
plus
it's racing game volume five
open world racing game volume five sorry
[Music]
so uncharted 4 is that like just a
nathan drake volume 4 like oh we're not
doing that we're not doing that no no
we're doing that we're doing that
because to me
core gameplay hasn't changed that whole
franchise from what i see go ahead and
talk entertain them real quick someone
keeps calling me i'm gonna make sure
everything's okay yes yes yes first of
all let me respond to this uh this
uncharted slander by the way let me
respond to this uncharted slander
first of all those games are legendary i
beat the first one beat the second one
halfway through the third one and i beat
lost legacy the difference is the story
in those games and they actually improve
the game play over time
number two
number two
look
put a story in the joint and then you
know then we talking make make for me
for me make me care about the car or
make me care about the character maybe
because you can't care about no damn bmw
or no dodge charger unless mine get a
damn accident that's the only way i'm
gonna care about the joint i'm sorry
i can care less about the cost
sorry
no matter what maybe that car has to go
through something the way like addict
said earlier the car gets stolen you got
to find a way to get it back and
and the need for speed i know no edit
can hear me
the need for speed games anyway that
story was pretty bad now i know he's a
little bit younger than me so he's gonna
have a different take on it that story
was pretty bad because i think that was
the story the way dudes in your car took
your girl and you was um
you was actually being entailed by the
cops you know you got pulled over and
like the black copy is scratched here
like keyed up your car and all that and
i don't know it's on x play
go watch it if you don't know what i'm
talking about
i'm good on that man there is no way
that you can compare like
whatever racing game to uncharted to god
chartered you can't do it you know
you know while attic you know he's doing
what he got to do and i'm taking over
oh i was going to take over the whole
show
i was just letting you get your bars off
that i've been back i was going to grow
some people in the chat
with me man because they coming at you
look this is an iop man if you come in
with the smoke we coming right back all
right
no hey i appreciate i appreciate all the
comments and everything um dallas thank
you for the compliment give me my choice
look man
you know you throw a story on forza man
i don't know maybe maybe if you know you
might want to throw one of those
characters in there they super chat
because they so upset with you right now
what's up
so okay okay okay so i think this first
one this first one's for me man okay so
okay uh two dollars two percent uh
x initiative did i get it that right
sophonic
c phonic
oh my god he got it in here i had to
look for
t take us and do it again
we look man
look if i messed up again
like look let's be real you guys get
enjoyment out of me mispronouncing stuff
so we go act like you don't
we go act like that
but let's go and read the super chat we
got a two dollar super chat from
sophonic initiative slander my name
slander forza
where are we
i don't know who he's talking about
because i feel like that could be on
both of us
seafood okay seafood he says
it's sifu poetic
x initiative
i'm probably going to miss that remo not
look i have a bad memory in a lot of
different cases
the game on playstation the new game on
playstation says i'm in the bushes
oh no
all right man you because i messed up
your name you have every right to throw
me in those bushes you have every right
uh so you had a super chat so i don't
know who he's talking about he said
slander my name
i'm pretty sure that's me i don't think
you slandered i mean we both might have
slandered it so i messed it up but i
don't think i was slandering forza so i
think he's talking about you
and and uh is that lucious augustus let
me let me let me let me read that cause
i think he's talking about little old me
over here
he said i'm talking about you yeah yeah
yeah i see him i'm not gonna block him
thank you for your super chat we
appreciate it we appreciate it um he
says
crazy that every shooting game is just
the shooter hey listen listen
give him that smoke man give him that
smoke
lucius give him that smoke don't let
this man come at you
i'm not sure if that's bart simpson in
the avatar with dressed up i'm not sure
what that is shout out to you by the way
every shooter ain't the shooter we know
every gun charter ain't uncharted of
course nathan drake is nathan every
uncharted is uncharted they're all the
most identical we hide somewhere you
shoot you move on you have a cutscene
you hide somewhere you shoot you move on
you have a cutscene it's literally the
same thing in every game
what's the defining factor that forza
doesn't have that's right a story that's
what i'm saying look everything changes
everything changed
from nathan elena sully nadine chloe my
baby
and sam the guy who i don't like and
everybody else in the whole myriad of
characters you know some of the super
villains in that or some of the
protagonists or antagonists rather in
the games they it was like cool to be
around you know there was a little
ruthless you understand like it's a lot
going on in them uncharted games and i
feel like we're not doing that no
justice i'm gonna do a retrospective on
the whole series when i'm finished all
the games
i got you on that so i'm gonna explain
that to everybody else and i'm gonna
make sure that i probably clip a little
bit of this here up in the video and i'm
gonna end up doing because we're not
having that we're not having that
every shooter ain't no shooter sir
look i don't know if i said that
this just isn't for unchartered
uh i will i brought this up because it's
for everything uh a lot of sequels have
very solid foundations to their
predecessors i i it's you know besides
gears 5 in terms of like the open world
a lot of the gears play identical it's
just the gameplay becomes more uh
becomes more definitive and it gets
better that doesn't mean it's a bad
thing that's not a bad thing
and that's why i feel like forza came
out the gate
a very polished racing game forza
horizon especially with two that's when
it really and i felt like they came out
the gate so much
that
they've increased stuff but nothing
drastically and i don't think that's a
bad thing i think at the end of the day
the most important thing is if it's fun
and the consumers are liking it clearly
more than one more than a million people
bought that uh early access thing for
forza so there is a huge demographic of
people that really enjoy that because
the only way to get access to that game
oh look is there reviewers such as
myself that was in that shirt but how
many could they have possibly been in
the
mail you know what i'm saying maybe 500
maybe a thousand do you really think
microsoft sent a thousand review copies
out there you know what i'm saying like
i don't think they did but i don't know
i don't know anything about that so you
know i'm not gonna make definites on
something i don't know but you know we
got 170 people in here man hit that like
button man hit that like button uh
please do get those likes up man let's
get those likes up above 100
and hustle will dance for us
oh no
no he won't
so you know
i
as far as forza horizon
i do feel like
if
if it's the best game out that year i do
think it deserves it uh this year's
subjective uh you know i think and keep
in mind it's a subjective opinion uh
people's gaming years is going to be
different from everywhere and i just
personally feel like it doesn't matter
what genre you are if you were the best
game out that year you should be in that
i think it's kind of pathetic low key
that the video game awards make the
racers in the in the sports game share a
genre yeah that's that's wild to me if
it
maybe it's because forza
is so dominant in the racing market
there's not a whole lot of racers out
there to really compete with it
maybe that's it you know maybe it's not
necessarily more on the vgas but more on
developers making these type of games so
if there's not more than two or three a
year and sometimes not even that how are
you going to realistically have a genre
in that so you have to bond with them
with someone else
um
uh yeah and it's a tad bit disrespectful
for this reason
i don't consider for forza horizon the
horizon series in general that can't
compete with a grand
excuse me gran turismo i'll say grand
theft auto that can't compete with a
grand tourism they got the same thing
gran turismo and then the motorsport
like those are like more of the same
thing
grant uh what's that false or horizon
like for me that's more in line with the
mario kart that's more in line with
crash team racing that's
that's the fun one for the family and
that's that's what that is that's like
the arcadey version that is the nba jam
to
the nba 2k y'all understand what i'm
saying how once an arcade was a
simulation that's kind of what that is
to me
and having all of that together like
there's no way you can compare a racing
game to a football game or basketball
like
you can't do it you can't i'm not
rolling i'm not rolling on that um not
for horizon not for horizon yes sir part
of me wants them to be separate but the
other part he's like
man if i can get these these sports
games up out of here um let's do it like
uh you know
i appreciate you know we're gonna we're
probably going to i do want to talk
about this real quick
uh you know
apparently i didn't watch it yet because
i haven't had a chance for those who
don't know i've worked 12 to eighths so
this is how my tuesdays are i go to work
at 12 get off at 8 in the morning
try to go to sleep immediately when i
get home but i'm sure a lot of you know
that when you get home you have that
adrenaline i'm off work so it keeps you
up for like an hour at least so then i
go to bed like nine sometimes tennis i
wake up at three to four to prepare for
the podcast and then uh and then like i
literally go to work like three or four
hours of sleep uh so you know i i'm
still i'm still kicking man i'm still
kicking but
i didn't get a watch yet because there
was so much stuff going on apparently
ryan mccaffrey has an interview out with
todd howard about star field
about you know just their games in
general and they talked about fall out
are you a fan of fallout do you like the
fallout franchise nah but i never really
been but but again like as far as like
the western rpgs that ain't really my
thing like the only two jrpgs i played
was mario rpg and persona 5. i don't
really
and that's perfectly fine you know what
i just want to ask and you know talk
about real quick uh probably five ten
minutes is he said that they had a
concept art uh they have a concept
pretty much like very light
like outline pretty much of what fallout
the next fallout's going to be
regardless if they call it fallout 5 or
they just because i've noticed that the
industry is starting to go away from
numbers they're trying to start the name
stuff just uh a certain uh you know i
they um halo infinite it's not halo 6
it's a little infinite
i've noticed that some of the industry's
moving towards this so
the fact that far cry might be years and
years and years away do you think that
that might be an issue or do you think
that uh you know star filled and do you
think that's
elder scrolls is enough to keep that
that studio busy for the foreseeable
future
oh oh it's the latter um they're going
to be more they're going to be busy
they're going to be super busy and the
fact that the both of those games are
going to be in game pass anyway they're
definitely going to be busy um seeing
early an early concept or something
i'm definitely cool with it even though
i'm not
keen on like those type of you know
games shout out to bethesda out there in
bethesda maryland right around the
corner from where i'm at even though i
two toucan on it i think i'm just
talking about it now i'm okay with it
but they're gonna be more than busy with
um with everything else um you said they
were remaking um
what game is that
not not starfield that's the new one
it's the it's the other one elder
scrolls right cause they're making that
one
hey they're gonna be busy they'll be all
right now i'll probably talk about like
20 24.
uh
what uh elder scrolls
yeah i would say that yeah we probably
won't see this game like 2027 though man
they that's this this this is a little
ways away i'd be surprised if we
heard about this game if we start
hearing about it in 2025
just in terms of like rumblings it's the
early thing that's that in the third
the night
what's up you know go ahead and finish
your statement no i was just gonna say
plus it's really it's not even needed
because we got a vowed around the corner
like xbox is running the uh the wrpg's
they're running them joints
like it's it's that it's um
shout out to shout out to megan
over there at obsidian it's um
the name of the game that i said i was
going to buy attic a dmg i can't think
of the name of it it's captain home
assumption and i said i was
um
it's coming out with a secret when i
can't think of the name of it to save my
life but that's only because i woke up
three o'clock this morning sorry uh but
atticu it's the it's the other game that
you guys have that um had the two guests
on um the iron lords podcast oh our
worlds out of worlds yes so we got other
worlds one out of worlds two then you
got fable coming up
ain't no rush
i wouldn't even rush it like i wouldn't
even sit like for real i guess you saved
the whatever to build some type of buzz
but i wouldn't even be saying that
because you don't need to say nothing at
that point
you only i wouldn't even yeah you don't
got to say nothing
i think
in terms of fallout i do think
that they don't
like
they need to do something with that
franchise sooner rather than later
um you know
they got such a talented ip of such a
beloved ip
don't think you need to wait till 20
20 30 to bank that game to have that
game out uh so i do feel like that you
know
reach out to you know i don't want them
to
i don't want them to outsource it i
don't want that but i do feel like
between obsidian
and between
uh
exile the people that make wasteland i
feel like someone can make
a fallout like it doesn't have to be but
that's the software studio and le if
everyone is willing you know what i'm
saying like and it's like when i bring
up stuff like
banjo-kazooie where i say you know
there's plenty of people
in those studios that want that
they want that chance they want that
chance to really go out there and be
something to go out there and give them
give them the reins like there's plenty
of people that's thirsty for that so
it's like take some from both studios so
people that really want you know get you
someone that's been very good at what
they do
let them be the lead and let them pick a
couple people that's not going to hurt
the project they're currently working on
and then then you know hire a couple
more people and have another team work
on fallout because like to me
fallout isn't an important brand but
it's not
absolute absolutely either keep in mind
we've had fallouts pretty consistently
for a minute we had fallout 76 fallout
4. uh you know they brought the fallout
franchise uh to the xbox backwards
compatibility list but fallout is a very
big name in the rpg market
and i do think that if you wait that
long by the time the game comes out it's
going to be irrelevant so you know i if
you know talk to people at obsidian you
know some people might be tired of
making a vow
in the outer world say you know we have
this secret secret project going on over
here it's like you know we're gonna
we're gonna work on
fallout do you want to be part of that
and if they're willing to do that and
it's not gonna affect outer worlds or
avowed let them go over there and do it
because i feel like
having a good like right now i feel like
if they play their cards right and
there's not a huge inconvenience in
terms of
the studios that are making something
like something like covet or something
something that delays a game a
significant amount of time
they have enough high quality rpgs that
they can make an rpg every that like
they can have rpg coming out of high
quality every year
not having fallout in that engine is a
mistake
sure i'm tired of fallout i want elder
scrolls six
i don't want them to take away from
elder scrolls six if i had a choice
between having elder scrolls six and 20
24 them splitting that team up to make
fallout 5 on top of elder scrolls six
i'm gonna say keep all those people on
elder scrolls six because i'm tired to
see him fall out
but i know there's a lot of people that
don't like elder scrolls they like the
fallout franchise and i feel like that's
a huge demographic of people because a
lot of people like to they like to pew
pew stuff they like shooting stuff they
don't really like swords magic they
don't like the fantasy genre in general
so to me it's like look it's not
necessarily mad important but
if you wait till 20 30. like think about
that
20
30 20 29 20 28 that's a long time
yeah you might not live that long you
know what i'm saying like that that's a
long time
so to me
have
even if like
a couple people from obsidian a couple
people from exile and a couple people
from uh from bethesda's software studios
all come together to make you know
20 to 40 people and they hire a couple
more people to add on to that
having those individuals work on a
fallout while an elder scrolls as being
on worked on simultaneously while a
fable is being worked on simultaneously
while a vows being worked on
simultaneously is going to be better
than not doing it because by the time
they realize that they want to fall out
fall out and by the time they realize
that the the that the consumers really
want to fall out they were going to have
the situation right for now hustle
where stuff was made too late and we're
waiting years for it so it's like to me
at least have people in a room like a
small team 10 15 to 20 people
that are just deciding how they want it
made
and then if they ended up that that what
the the stuff that they're deciding is
enough relevancy and it sounds good
enough then pull the green light and
have it productive yeah um yeah and we
saw that we started with um
what's never that arachnophobia game
that i believe obsidian made
um grounded because i think i think it's
called grounded um we saw like a little
section go away for that but we we've
always seen like main teams and then
like little side teams always get
started on something so yeah i mean
we'll definitely see it and um you were
mentioned there earlier and i don't know
why i didn't think about it there will
be like different like pollination for
like those different studios or somebody
from nxl somebody from obsidian somebody
it's gonna it's gonna be a whole like
melting pot just to get something up off
the ground
so you know i see it
when i say 2027 earlier i didn't mean to
say it was necessarily take that long
for them to make i i'm just saying that
like they don't have to do it right away
it's cool that you would see something
like i get and i get why you would see
it because fallout 76 like they turned
it around but it started off like really
bad you know put had a sound taste in a
lot of people's mouth but
i'm just saying that you just you don't
have to do it right away we don't like
we probably like if it was me you know
if i was if it was man i was running it
i'll work on it in silence i wouldn't
say nothing i wouldn't have said
anything whatsoever but that that's just
me i would've just been like all right
cool i'm gonna send five from here five
from i'm gonna send five people from
like five different studios right
so get this kicked off right quick
what's up here's what i'm talking about
all right so
i'm looking at
a calendar for the next few years
so 2022
starfield 2023 about 2024
hopefully
between fable
and elder scrolls one of them's coming
out that year i don't know if faber was
going to be that long but there is a
possibility fable takes that long um
people want quality but they don't want
to wait for quality makes no sense 2025
the other one would probably come up
most likely star uh
elder scrolls uh elder scrolls five 2026
if they start a game now
fallout would be ready by that date
so imagine 2025 they they get all the
publicity they have stuff like uh you
know elder scrolls gets game of the year
or you know you know i'm being you know
completely optimistic on that but
almost every elder scrolls has been game
of the year so it's not a stretch to say
that it doesn't have the potential and
by the time they get to that fallout
2027 would be the new
then obsidian's ready again and keep in
mind out of worlds 2 somewhere in around
here um
the next star field might be ready by
that time and then they could literally
restart the engine and do it all over
again
yeah it's microsoft they got a team
behind them boy oh xbox games right they
got they got them teams behind them and
that'd be a hell of a rollout like if
you if you're a wrpg fan in particular
like that like for me how you broke all
that down that would be like the
uncharted for me that would be that you
know that would be
every year i might i might off myself
man well i'm just saying different games
in general that that would be uncharted
that would be you know god of war that
would be ratchet and clank that would be
they were and that would just be wrpg's
at that point it's not with gears right
it's not with halo it's just with that
genre of of games so like
yeah i mean you know
and i i i'm confident that they'll roll
it out in such a fashion way i figure
every year maybe every year and a half
we'll see something we'll see like a new
rpg i feel like
they might get such a big first off i
think the biggest issue microsoft's
going to have is when stuff's going to
come out i do think we're going to get
to a point in the future well they're
pushing stuff back that's completely
done
because they don't want it to eat their
other snacks you know yeah you're not
you're not going to put
you uh you know hellblade and avowed in
the same month
so they're going to have to push one of
them back naturally and you know i think
we're probably i think the rpgs the high
quality rpgs them suck is coming out of
the holidays of every year
yeah and i think you're going to get the
hellblades the very high quality types
of games people like those are the
marches the april's you know what i'm
saying and i think they're going to do
that man i think it's it's looking real
good you know we're going to go ahead
and close this out man
hustle where can the people find you now
what are you doing here lately
where can they find you well hey i'll be
streaming i'm definitely streaming so um
i'm off veterans day but i will be
streaming on twitch
and or youtube
probably super mario who knows i have no
clue i probably i thought if if it'll
run right we saw some things on twitter
earlier today shout out to slo-mo for
that i saw some things that i really
wasn't comfortable with but i got two
pcs so i probably stream some forza
worse from the worst i'm streaming super
mario because i always you know a lot of
the retro stuff and i got a question
before we go yes
can we uh raid someone who we both know
who
jack move johnny
yeah yeah we can write jackman if i like
jack thank you sir that's my guy right
there one of the reasons why i'm here
the other reason is this girl right here
haircuts for the win anyway
yes you know kiki going tell them where
are you at
oh twitter youtube twitch
all of them all i'm hustling motivate
somebody followed me earlier thank you
for that if you want some uh
hijinks so to speak if you want you want
to see some some tweeted out music you
know and if you just want to see like
you know me supporting a whole lot of
other people following me there i have a
good time um
it was fun as always man and i cannot
wait for you to play this
i'll be real with you it's friday friday
probably 5 p.m friday i'm going to make
sure i'm in the crib
so
obviously hustle said you know friday on
this channel 5 p.m friday i will be
streaming
ninja gaiden for the nhs you know what's
funny i actually i have to play it on
the switch because oh
we were going to do
other methods
but uh but
saul felt uncomfortable doing other
methods so
you know obviously we don't want to
encourage like stuff like that so i will
be playing that on the switch because it
is on the switch
we had to buy some stuff to make sure i
can put it on the uh because i i don't
have a thing for the dock anymore
so you know i had a he had to buy that
so that's here that's probably at my
mailbox right now
so i i'm gonna get that so be here
friday
at 5 00 p.m
to see me struggle in quotations i don't
know if i'm be struggling yet but to see
me doing that man and i'm gonna be real
man that
you guys be nice in that chat man you
might hit me up for a super chat or two
maybe i stay on that and do it longer
you know if it makes sense to me i might
do it longer you could you guys good
enough i do that till i beat it but you
know um so definitely going to there uh
so go ahead uh we got we got our friend
jack blue johnny man i'm gonna put his
uh his link in the chat now let me let
me get some quotations here let me get
some some advertising jack move is a
very extra individual sometimes so i'm
gonna put his stuff in the chat but he's
a very passionate person and i do feel
like you know some of you might like him
uh you know
some of you might not like
but he has a playstation channels keep
that in mind xbox people and he has a
very smoky channel you go on there
you're gonna get that smoke if you come
at him but it's true
it's very entertaining so go in there
tell them the iron lords podcast sent
you man tell them addicts sent you don't
tell them iop some addicts that you i
wanted to know addicts sent you so tell
them attic and hustle sent you man and
you know i appreciate everyone coming
through here and i hope you guys enjoy
uh your day man we'll be back here i
don't know if we'll have a podcast next
week because there's some stuff going on
next week i will get back to you guys
later on this week about that but i
appreciate everyone for coming through
here man this is addict hustle where
what's your twitter tell me your twitter
real quick hustling motivated on twitter
that's what i am motivated the same way
it comes up in the chat yeah and it is
in the description so i'll talk to you
guys later and